a popular messaging service faces
criticism for allowing the terrorists
involved in the London attack to
communicate in secret Khalid Massoud is
believed to have used whatsapp moments
before his deadly rampage on Westminster
Bridge investigators can't access the
message because it was encrypted we're
learning more about Melissa Cochran the
Utah woman hurt in that attack it was
her husband Curt who was killed their
family just spoke at a news conference
and Jonathan Vigliotti is that London
Scotland Yard Jonathan good morning and
good morning that press conference
wrapping up just a few minutes ago
Melissa not inside as you mentioned
she's still recovering at the hospital
but her family was here 11 in all many
of them flying from Utah to be by her
side her health is steadily improving
and she has been strengthened by the
presence of her family she is so
grateful for the outpouring of love and
generosity Melissa Cochran's brother
says she is recovering from a broken leg
and rib but her mother Sandra says she's
just coming to terms with the attack
that took her husband Curt's life
immediately after the attack this photo
emerged of Melissa laying on the ground
and she had the strength in her eyes
that she looked at the camera can you
describe the shrink now that she has in
this recovery process it was
heart-wrenching for us to see this
picture of her and I see that she's had
some hard times and I've every day I've
seen her get stronger Melissa and Kurt
were on the last day of their dream
European vacation when they became some
of the first victims the Utah couple was
walking on Westminster Bridge when the
speeding car struck them Melissa was
thrown into a souvenir stand Kurt went
over the side of the bridge and fell
onto a concrete slab 20 feet below the
circumstances under which he was killed
obviously are horrific and you know I
think we all feel terrible that it
happened but you know it happened and we
love him still in all four people were
killed when Colleen masood drove his
rented car on the sidewalk of the
age before crashing into a gate at
Parliament Melissa and Kurt were here to
celebrate their 25th wedding anniversary
they love to take photos their family
today saying before they returned home
to Utah they wanted to come here to
Westminster Bridge to take a photo in
front of Big Ben Gail boy Jonathan thank
you the more details you hear the worse
it gets it could happen to anybody you
think you're on vacation it's your last
day and that happens you know you never
know you're right charlie glad her
family's with her now Thank You Jonathan
Vigliotti reporting from London